une phrase vous savez qu'il célèbre qui
nous donne encore la chair de poule
on parle avec un autre astronaute il a
été d'ailleurs le premier astronaute
canadien restait plus de 200 jours dans
l'espace
il va maintenant nous raconter comment
il avait vécu personnellement les
premiers pas de l'homme sur la lune ont
rejoint d'ailleurs robert thirsk dans le
studio de toronto bonjour monsieur est
un bon jour où les biens merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous pour cet événement
historique
on va reculer dans le temps voulez vous
on va reculer en 1969
évidemment lors de la mission d'apollo
11 je crois que vous aviez 15 ans
possiblement quels souvenirs
il en reste pour vous oui exactement
rejeté à 15 ans et j'étais très
impressionnée enthousiasmé par la
mission d'apollo 11
à l'est les astronautes à propos mais on
rentre en buzz aldrin les autres sont
devenus les héros et leurs exploits
leur mission a vraiment à ont influencé
mon choix d'éducation et évidemment il
n'a carrière satisfaisante
ouais parce qu'alors que lorsqu'ils sont
jeunes 15 ans 16 ans 17 ans vous savez
monsieur woerth
ils ont parfois des grands poster ou des
grandes affiches
deux vedettes du rock notamment vous
vous vedette c'était vraiment ces
hommes-là neil armstrong buzz aldrin
notamment oui le 16 6 astronautes sont
les héros de tout tout le monde c'était
une mission de américaine mais tout le
monde
on a le sentiment que c'était un nouveau
voyage pour toute l'humanité et
peut-être dans le canada nous avons
développé un enthousiasme après ni après
boys pour les défis à l'équipe de grands
défis de la jours exactement est ce
qu'on pourrait dire que ça éveillé ou à
tout le moins renforcer une curiosité
pour l'espace qui était déjà présente
pour vous est-ce que c'est cela qui vous
inspirait devenir astronaute
ah oui à mais avant ça j'étais aussi
également impressionné par l'émission
des démissions précédent par exemple ont
piqué qu'il y ait la mission de john
green et après chaque mission quatre
mois après chaque mission demeure cui
jian apollo je me rendais aux
bibliothèques locales pour lire les
récits et pouvoir les photos incroyables
de ces missions est vraiment c'était une
grande influence de suivre une carrière
dont l'exploration pour moi ouais c'est
ça on pourrait dire que c'est vous
on pourrait dire amener le chemin
inverse évidemment votre grande carrière
l'émission d'appels ou est ce que c'est
important également pour le programme
spatial canadien motors
oui beaucoup des ingénieurs canadiens en
contribuer au programme de polo par
exemple la conception de la démission
lunaire la formation des astronautes
d'apollo et aussi la construction d'un
vaisseau spatial du néant et les choses
comme les antennes
maintenant aujourd'hui le nas en bons
réglages pour le canada et nos
compétences nous avons au canada de
développer les compétences une
réputation internationale de
télécommunication robotique
observation du terme et bien cela les
vaisseaux l'émission spatiaux a eu mines
vous avez intégré et un tweeter donc
j'ai fait des petites recherches l'ont
le regard des programmes spatial
canadien dans les années 80 vous avez
fait des vols dans les années 80 est
aussi 90 et vous avez été aussi le
premier canadien à vous envoler à bord
de la fusée soyouz en 2009 quel
sentiment
racontez-nous saura quels sentiments
quelle émotion ressent avant de quitter
la planète a beaucoup d'émotion
premièrement à la peur les l'evora
spatiales sont toujours très présentes
vraiment lorsqu'on est évidemment dans
la capsule dans la fusée oui oui c'est
toujours dangereux mais aussi nous
traînons de faire une erreur dans dans
l'espace aussi c'est important pour les
astronautes de fonctionner bien dans
l'espace
deuxièmement la fierté c'est une chose
incroyable de représenter mon pays dans
une milieu international et aussi la
joie la joie de suivre une rêve
d'enfance et de réaliser une telle rêve
oui et sur place monsieur tout comment
ça se passe à la vous étiez resté je
m'abuse six mois
comment on se sent en apesanteur
évidemment lors de très très grande
période on vient mons dans l'espace et
c'est bizarre mais ce real en flotte
comment on flotte beaucoup faute
beaucoup comme superman comme l'espère
humaine
on a l'occasion de voir le tiers à
travers les fenêtres de la station et ça
change les priorités individuel les
prescriptions de l'humanité c'était une
chose incroyable et comme vous savez
tous les systèmes du corps change à dans
la présente les muscles et que les eaux
c'est une chose un petit peu désarmée
l'est le humaine est une chose très
adaptable
oui absolument vous devez aussi vous
savez et david saint-jacques vous étiez
d'ailleurs pour commenter sur la buse
il ya quelques semaines qui a ressenti
des effets physiques lorsqu'il est
revenu sur terre est ce que ça a été la
même chose pour vous lors de votre
retour
oui il est un autre adaptation à au
caire après une mission de longue durée
j'ai soufflé de même sorte de maladie
que david le premier jour après le très
sage
je souffrais de l'étourdissement et la
pression de décembre étaient basés pour
moi j'ai j'ai besoin de les fluides un
terminus pour m'aider mais coeur mais
tous ces adaptations sont nos mails
après c'est normal et c'est dur
justement de vue notamment les
vomissements et c'est tout à fait normal
lorsqu'on revient sur terre oui oui
exactement le mal de mer où la demande
de l'espace encore après le retour après
peut-être six semaines auquel david
saint-jacques sentira normale a encore
il a un bon entraîneur
maintenant pour ajuster adapté auteurs
lorsqu'on revient sur terre qui est une
à une revendication lorsqu'on revient
sur twitter est-ce qu'on sent un peu
comme un athlète qui met un terme à sa
carrière
est-ce qu'on se demande ce qu'on fera
est ce qu'un risque que tous deviennent
banales finalement sur terre un bon
question peut-être vous avez entendu
dire des astronautes d'apollo qui en
souffre de problèmes psychologiques
après une telle mission
par exemple mais pour moi c'était pas le
cas a pour moi après
après mon carrière comme astronaute je
suis toujours export j'aime d'explorer
les nouveaux frontières le médecine au
caire le 6 ans le génie et pour moi
c'est toujours une aventure après mon
cas mais voyage dans l'espace
toujours intéressant de vous entendre
merci beaucoup monsieur tort et je
rappelle aussi que vous participer à
l'événement qui est organisée par l'
agence spatiale canadienne célébrer les
50 ans d'apollo 11 alors c'est cet après
midi au centre des sciences à toronto et
à david saint jacques il y en a qui sera
au centre des sciences à montréal merci
beaucoup